notre pays avait pas forcément la
culture du masque au début de cette
crise culture qui a été acquise après
des années de pratique dans d'autres
pays vous le constatez sans doute comme
moi que dans la rue dans le métro
parfois le port du masque un peu bizarre
on enlève on met dans sa poche
on leur met on a un geste régulier parce
que le truc et manage sûr que vous
portez des lunettes ça vous fait des
trucs de la buée donc vous essayé tant
bien que mal de le remettre alors
j'espère avoir eu les bons gestes en
excuser moi mais vous n'avez pas les
bons gestes parce que le fait de croiser
oui ça sort ça sort latéralement donc ça
perd son efficacité non j'ai demandé
tous pareils on a tous de la mue et
rassurez vous c'est pas ce pessimisme
sur le comprend glacis voilà ce que ce
que je voulais vous dire et c'est les
c'est pour ça pour le coup je vous le
dis c'était une famille qui était
maladroite je le reconnais complètement
mon objectif à ce moment-là et aide au
fonds de dire ce que j'aurais peut-être
dû dire simplement que c'était on était
à la fois dans un moment où il y avait
pas de recommandations consensuelles sur
le port du masque en population générale
il y avait une recommandation de l' oms
notamment qui était de dire la priorité
doit aller au personnel soignant et
c'est comme ça qu'on a travaillé et dans
et deuxième chose nous avions
par ailleurs un pays où la culture du
mas n'existait pas c'est ce que j'essaie
d'exprimer gelé mal exprimé je sais ce
que ça veut dire merci pour cette note
d'autocritique
c'est damien regnard c'est damien
regarde je vous ai écorché le je vous
remercie pour cette précision sur le
port du masque effectivement je pense
que c'est important de le rappeler
régulièrement et on voit des choses
assez cocasse quelquefois mais je crois
qu'on a déjà progressé un petit peu
puisque vous venez d'avouer et de dire
que votre formulation était maladroite
donc ça prouve bien comme le demandent
et madame de roche et et notre président
tout à l'heure est ce qu'il ya un peu
une autocritique
est ce qu'on peut progresser est ce que
si la situation perdure est ce qu'on va
rester sur cette tête de ce ce type de
communication ou bien est ce que il y a
eu des erreurs de communication
voilà donc cesser c'est un peu
l'objectif de cette commission enquête
dont je vous remercie en tout cas de
votre réponse